re me It's really interesting to be able to express what I imagined in such a big form in front of a lot of spectators, isn't it
?
The Nebuta is framed with a wire, and paper is put on it to turn on electricity to the inside. It
takes about a year to make the Nebuta, considering the concept of the Nebuta. The
width of the Nebuta is the old meter
height.  It's about 5 meters with a trolley.
Well, every year the idea is various movies, TV, going to museums
, watching books, but the snow is the life of the creator
.
I think that what happens in such a living home is influenced by the blue sky.
[Music] The
Nebuta Festival seems to have been going on for about 300 years.
Such a big mountain car is the Nebuta Festival.  There are 22 of
them. The reason why I started to make a series of calls with Nebuta was that my father was also making 2 and he
was watching his appearance and he was working hard to protect it.
I don't want to let people feel sleepy,
so now I'm the only woman's sound 2 c.
Before I made my debut as a Nebuta teacher, the other policies are men.  In
the
old days, it was said that it was difficult for women to express a masculine seam like
that, but
the situation in Japan is getting stronger now.
I think that even women can express that kind of courage that they were late
.
I
didn't expect to receive such a wonderful prize at that time when my work received the Nebuta Grand Prize, so to be honest, I don't really
feel it.  I mean, it's
really big 4
[Music] It's
2 next year, but
I want to do it so that I can make the work of that time on my own without paying too much
[Music]